la estación de tren de kramators
actualmente
la ciudad más importante o el centro del
corazón de lo que queda de esta región
de dones que en control de las fuerzas
ucranianas esta escena diariamente de
una de esas imágenes tristes y
rompedoras que deja la guerra en Ucrania
aquí llegan a las 2 de la tarde antes de
que salga el tren a la ciudad de quiefa
a las 12:35 cientos de parejas las
mujeres han venido a visitarlos por
varios días Aprovechando que está allá
en operativo el tren este tren estuvo
inhabilitado por varios meses después de
un trágico ataque que hubo aquí el año
pasado el 8 de abril donde murieron 61
personas desde entonces la estación
estuvo cerrada hasta el 14 de octubre
que se volvió a reabrir y así muchas
parejas y muchos militares aprovecharon
de que el descanso que tienen para ir
hasta sus ciudades es bastante
limitado muchos de ellos solamente lo
han hecho una vez desde que comenzó la
guerra Así que aprovechan a que sus
mujeres vengan hasta aquí estén dos o
tres días o hay veces una semana
alquilan un apartamento y tratan de
rehacer una vida normal antes de que
ellas tengan que volver a partir como
está sucediendo en este momento en uno
de esos momentos que se les ve llorar y
es muy triste porque aquí en el donba se
vive en algunas de las batallas o si no
las batallas más difíciles de esta
guerra estaba
y muchos de estos hombres pelean en esas
batallas y ahora incluso más de Cara a
esa contraofensiva que se anuncia desde
Ucrania y que nadie se sabe realmente lo
que va a pasar así que aquí en este
momento vemos como muchos se despiden se
dicen adiós y todos tienen ese
sentimiento de que no saben si será la
última vez